First of all, I'd like to ask
you a question.
What is beauty?
Beauty is a single word, but we use it
to describe a billion different things.
And it's this universal concept that
is totally subjective.
How would you determine if something
else is beautiful?
What does it mean
when something isn't beautiful?
Wait, where are my manners?
A very good evening
to the beautiful ladies
and most certainly handsome gentlemen,
fellow TED speakers,
and everyone present today.
Throughout our lives, we are surrounded
by a cacophony of noise
telling us what we should do,
how we should act,
and who we should be.
Not convinced?
Long hair, a fair complexion, sexy eyes,
luscious lips, perky breasts,
a small waist, a flat stomach,
a shapely bum, long legs,
finally finishing with a symmetrical body
completes the ideal look of physically
perfect woman.
However, if I were to tell you that these
stereotypes only apply to women,
I would be lying.
His hair is a stylish chaos,
the eyes, deep and captivating,
the jawline, masculine and chiseled,
broad shoulders, chest muscles, six-pack
abs, rippling biceps, a wide back,
oh, and he must be six feet and above.
From the broad chest of Superman
to the tiny waists of Disney princesses,
our perception of beauty has been
so greatly influenced by the media
that we subconsciously accept these
requirements as being true and just.
Therefore, nowadays people are boycotted,
isolated, discriminated, even,
because they are thought of as ugly,
or different, for that matter.
And that's why in the pursuit of beauty,
people tend to go overboard
and finally become something they're not.
Twelve years ago, The Swan took the world
by storm,
being described as Jennifer Pozner as the
most sadistic reality show of the decade.
Now, The Swan is a 2004 American reality
television program
in which women who were judged
to be ugly
were given extreme makeovers
to fulfill their greatest fantasies.
Contestants collectively received more
than 4 million dollars worth of treatment
including tummy tucks,
breast augmentations,
rhinoplasty, jaw and nose reconstruction,
laser hair removals,
I'm just saying This is an extremely
complicated and time-consuming process,
not to mention the agonizing
physical pain
these people have
to endure over two months.
Some of them were happy.
That's good.
But for some, relationships crumbled,
some gained weight,
some of them contemplated suicide,
and for some of them,
they still suffer
from depression, agoraphobia,
and crippling mental disorders.
This might seem staggering,
ladies and gentlemen,
yet thousands of individuals
squealed in delight
when they were told that they
were chosen to become a Swan
because they were sick of being
called ugly,
they were sick of insecure marriages,
and this is the product of our
beauty-obsessed culture.
Yet another blight that consumes
so many young people
is anorexia nervosa,
an eating disorder that is characterized
by a fear of weight gain
leading to malnutrition
or excessive weight loss.
Kirsten Haglund was 19 when she became
Miss America in 2008,
one of the youngest beauty queens
ever to win the national title.
Yet, she was the victim of anorexia.
She now uses this platform of her title
to raise awareness
about this very sensitive subject.
She was struggling with this disturbing
disorder since the age of twelve.
Consuming fewer than 900 calories daily,
less than half the recommended
for the average woman her age,
she became obsessed with the need
to reduce her weight even further.
Starving herself and adding even
more exercise to her regular routine
and demanding schedule,
she arrived to a nearly
irreversible condition.
If not for the help of her mother
and multiple specialists,
she would have reached a point
of no return.
And all of this is for the sake of fitting
herself into the image of beauty,
inculcated into her mind by the
questionable standards of our society.
From time to time, I wonder.
Why do we hold physical traits
with such high regard?
Do we not realize that what's inside
is far more important?
I mean, you might have the gratification
of looking great,
and you might have that satisfaction
of fitting into a smaller shirt,
but besides showing that you've
changed your appearance,
what else does that say about you?
Now, let me show you
guys something special,
something you might not believe.
So this is me when I was ten years old.
As you can see, I was fat,
like really, really fat,
but it didn't bother.
I mean, I played tennis and badminton,
and everything,
but man, I just loved eating.
So I just ate and ate
and got fatter and fatter
until I reached puberty,
when I just slimmed down all of a sudden.
You see, I completely forgot
I looked like this
until one day I was going
through old photos.
I just went, "oh my goodness!"
I rushed to my mom, I said,
"Mom, how could you let me
look like this?"
But she was puzzled and said,
"Look like what?"
"This! This!"
She laughed and said, "Oh you mean
looking fat?
Ryan, you're my son, I love you,
and nothing will every change that."
And it was that moment when I just got it.
Look, I was more than just a fat kid.
I was positive, I was cheerful,
I was helpful,
I might not have had the best physique,
according to society, that is,
but I have never lacked friends,
and throughout my life, I have always
had happy people around me.
However you may look like on the outside,
it is your character
that makes you truly shine.
Ladies and gentlemen, do we love
others just because of looks?
Don't we love them
because of who they are deep within?
Would we stop loving them
if they gained a few pounds,
developed acne, stopped putting
on makeup, or cut their hair?
A famous playwright once wrote,
"Do I love you because you are beautiful,
or are you beautiful because I love you?"
These words reflect the idea
that beauty is purely subjective,
and that it can from appreciation,
not just the other way around.
We need to educate our children
and grandchildren
that physical characteristics alone
do not constitute beauty.
We need to change and we need it now.
France, Spain, Italy, and Israel
have enacted legislations
banning overly skinny models.
Empowering hashtags, such as
"Honor My Curves,"
"Dare to Wear,"
and "Celebrate my Size"
has blown up over Instagram.
Body positive movements
are celebrated everywhere,
and this is a good thing.
The Body Positive Movement
is a movement that encourages people
to adopt a more affirming attitude
towards their bodies
with a goal of improving overall
health and fitness.
Because when we are able to live
peacefully inside our own bodies,
only then are we able to care for others
from a point of love and appreciation.
We need more diverse models
in the media,
be it in terms of race, height,
body size, skin color,
be it black or white, brown or yellow,
red or green, or blue or polka-dotted,
whatever!
We need diversity because
this world is diverse,
man, people are diverse.
Don't get me wrong, there is nothing
wrong with being skinny
or putting on makeup.
But there is nothing wrong with being
not skinny and not putting on makeup.
I'll tell you what, if you want to put
on weight, you put on weight.
If you want to slim down, you slim down.
If you want to hit the gym,
you hit the gym.
If you want to put on makeup every day,
you put on makeup every day.
If you want to dye your hair
in rainbow colors, I don't see why not.
Be whoever you want to be because
that is who you truly are.
Beauty is everywhere and inside everyone.
We may not be able to see
inner beauty in person,
but we can definitely feel it.
I would like to leave you with
these beautiful words by poet Erin Hanson.
You're made of so much beauty,
But it seems that you forgot,
When you decided that you were defined,
By all the things you're not.
Whoever they are are,
whatever they may say,
be strong, be different, Be-you-tiful.